I hear people say well this is this is
rich people wasting their money 250 000
ticket to go to the bottom of the ocean
look at the rich people wasting their
money first of all pound for pound it's
very likely that you have wasted more
money or at least you know if you look
at your total income versus how much
money you personally have wasted this
applies to me as well as a percentage
you have very likely wasted more money
than any of the rich people on that
submersible we're all guilty of wasting
money that's Modern Life like we fill
our lives and our homes with a whole
bunch of crap we don't need we all do
that and as your income increases you
just end up wasting more money you know
if you're not wasting as much money as a
billionaire it's probably just because
you don't have that much money to waste